fonds et destinées sentimentales du
jeune réalisateur français olivier
assayas c'est une épopée en costume que
nous résume tout de suite nicole cornu
langlois emmanuelle béart charles
berling le couple attachant
impressionnant des destinées
sentimentales un hymne à l'amour éternel
tout puissants imaginés par jacques
chardonne et mis en images par olivier
assayas
quand les ragots de ce qu'ils veulent au
début du dernier siècle il est pasteur
marié à isabelle huppert
il divorce qui tout pour elle pauline
rebelles indépendant passionnés ils
partent vivre ailleurs dans un chalet
suisse
les hommes mettent un peu de leur âme
dans beaucoup de choses et femmes aux
jeux pleins les femmes
demande tout à l'amour mais l'amour
c'est pas toute la vie ce sera toujours
l'un et l'autre l'un avec l'autre et
l'un grâce à l'autre et je crois aussi
une des forces de pauline c'est le
regard de gens c'est que je je je
j'ai toujours senti dans le regard de
gens et donc de charles que c'était un
homme qu'il a regardé dans la lumière ce
n'est pas un homme qu'il affronte asthme
il n'avait pas sur un piédestal il ne
lit d'alice pas et du coup il lui donne
une incroyable possibilité d'être
vivante mais enfin pas les animaux
j'habite à l'image avec cette fabrique
ses affaires un effroyable
laisse moi t'expliquer lennon laisse moi
t'expliquer m'expliquer à moi même je
n'ai pas travaillé pendant des années je
m'en bats c'est très bien mais ça c'est
un appel direct à ma compétence
une responsabilité familiale a un
instinct profond
le couple est confronté aux épreuves de
la séparation de la guerre des grèves
dans la fabrique de porcelaine qu'il a
repris en main à limoges c'est pas des
concepts généraux le cinéma sa part des
hommes sa part de de la terre sa part 2
ça parle des gens et c'est très
important et ça c'est un film qui prend
sa source là parmi les nombreux films de
ce festival consacré au couple avec ses
infidélités ces compromis cette saga
conjugale et la plus romanesque que la
plus ambitieuse même si la facture en
est un peu conventionnelles
mais quel beau couple